I think it would shock a lot of
Americans to know that in a 10-minute
cab ride from the Eiffel Tower you can
be walking through streets that feel
like Baghdad I think we'll have to sue I
think we'll have to go to court the
image of Paris has been prejudiced and
the honor of Paris to be virtuous hello
is it at least oh well ah
oh my god Mike I'm so afraid of piracy -
Chum yes ranking you Paris is a very
very dangerous city privilege of mass in
the world look at John now he was in the
terrorist richland Islamist very manga
fire is very digital come back John
Charlie students come back come back
run away really oh my god couscous we
have made some regrettable errors on air
regarding the Muslim population in
Europe now this applies especially to
discussions of so-called no-go zones so
sorry guys no fellow John de Soleil
Parilla from flikkema better for modular
Tojo my rendezvous couche avec ma